musée avait peut-être joué quand vous
étiez enfant c'était un alien avec une
casquette rouge son tee shirt était trop
petit et son nombril dépasser ses
oreilles étaient pointus comme celles de
dalian car c'était un alien messieurs
dames matelas d'applaudissements vous je
sais pas si vous avez connu à 10 ou ses
deux cousins adibou adibou tout mais
c'était les héros d'une série de jeux à
but éducatif d'acheter ces jeux à tes
enfants pour leur apprendre les maths
niveau ce2 ou le français niveau cp bref
c'était vraiment pour apprendre les
trucs à tes enfants en les stimulant mon
père m'avait acheté adibou adibou
c'était réservé aux 4 7 ans a dit
c'était pour les 10 14 ans et à 10 bouts
d'choux c'était pour entre 18 mois et 3
ans je sais pas comment tu fais pour
jouer un jeu vidéo quand tu as entre 18
mois et 3 ans mais bon ça existait
austria est là dessus franchement quand
on était gamin c'était où aujourd'hui il
ya des gens des leurs cinq ans ils
jouent à fifa n'ont joué a dit bout mon
pote ce combat je vous en faites pas je
fais un visite guidée du meilleur jeu
pour enfants de tous les temps et on
fait un deal quand vous aurez des
enfants plus tard et ben vous les ferez
jouer à ce jeu voilà je prends call of
comme ça tu le mets dans la poubelle et
tu le mets devant un deal ou tu vas t'on
gamins ils se trouvent mais bon on va
green games ce que tu manges la souris
une petite mans se déplace sur l'écran
si c'est un doigt pointé tu peux cliquer
l'écran n'est en aucun cas une main
plate
tu ne peux plus cliqués la main peut
prendre d'autres formes selon tes
besoins adibou s'te plaît mec mais je te
qui fut à l'époque ménages commence à
détester ce que j'ai là c'est que là
c'est un jeu pour les 4 7 ans et
regardez comme ils expliquent déjà tu
imagines le jeu pour les 18 mois à 3 ans
mais qui en fait y'a pas de jeu c'est
juste les explications pendant huit
heures c'est sûr bon alors là en gros
ont créé son avatar voilà les mecs
étaient perchés à fond les mecs étaient
vraiment perche et j'avais oublié je me
souviens que des fois j'avais peur parce
qu'ils étaient trop haut perchée et ce
que je vois ça me faisait un peu flipper
je vous promets c'est vrai mais quand on
se veut dire qu'un enfant il a pas peur
devant sa réellement là on est au top à
des boues à l'air vraiment très
sympathique j'aimerais que tu me donnes
ta date de naissance bas du dos à notre
regard pas déjà aux mondiaux l'interface
date et vous c'est incroyable ce qui se
passe bien oui tu peux t'amuser
mais pour y apprendre absolument oui
écoutez moi bien on va faire une petite
visite guidée ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va tous se retrousser nos manches
et vous allez suivre le guide
direction la maison d'adeeb ou all à la
mecque alors là pour ceux qui
connaissent pas dhibou pouvez pas savoir
à quel point cet endroit est le temple
de la satisfaction quand tu es enfant
mais vraiment ce qu'on joue a dit vous
vous souvenez du gâteau c'était deux
activités dans la digue où on s'en
souvient on va aller dans la cuisine tu
veux voir ma [ __ ] chadha qu il est
dehors ça n'a aucun sens quelqu'un vient
voler ton gâteau
et voilà vous venez de faire
connaissance avec le méchant dany boon
suisse appelle d'ailleurs on a moins bon
mais pas faire ce [ __ ] de gâteau c'est
très simple je me souviens comme si
c'était hier
oh oui ce robot mais qu'il est tellement
glauque ce robot mec je me souviens il
ya une manière de parler très bizarre on
dirait vraiment qu'il nous veut du mal
qui veut nous faire des choses très
sombre
moi j'étais un pro pour juste faire des
gâteaux chocolats stade je m'étais que
du chocolat ou la séquence de bruitages
et mais c'est ouf comme dans les jeux
pour enfants ils mettent des bruitages
bizarre pour tout tu cliques n'importe
où et 1 8 h ou à hessenheim hockey
moment de vérité est ce que mon gâteau
est réussi yes il n'a pas perdu la main
le lucas même quinze ans plus tard
ah oui aussi vous pouvez décorer c'est
vrai notamment que les petits pains plus
de ces ceux avec lesquels tu joues
pendant un repas de famille puisque tu
t'emmerdes et kick ass
au bout de deux minutes parce que c'est
pas du tout la qualité que le ring for
you vraiment je pense que tu vas finir
en prison un jour c'est de toute
évidence alors normal gâteau sur la taxe
[Musique]
au sac gentil père ce qui le mange donc
le gâteau est bon non non je crois que
c'est ça les bruitages et des bruitages
partout tout le temps ensuite tu pouvais
mélanger différents ingrédients qui vont
pas ensemble mais je crois que c'est le
méchant qui venaient manger le gâteau et
qui les met pas du tout voyons voir ce
que ça donne
yesh la gros gâteau dégueulasse je
connais bien je faisais côté comme ça
[Musique]
ok donc si vous aviez des doutes quand
tu mélanges du sucré et du salé
ça fait des flammes voilà ce que ça
voici les recettes que tu peux réaliser
chez toi à mes cd vraie recette à faire
dans la vraie vie à faire dans la vraie
vie avec tes parents c'est trop bien
qu'invaincus monde en france bon
l'atelier gâteau et personne n'a un
petit cordon bleu qu'est ce qu'on fait
tu vas juste arrêter de me couper la
parole pour commencer espèce de petit
ont tué d'alien oui mais ouais non
savoir plus d'interrogations
non non non on va pas de chance d'un
monologue de 20 minutes j'ai pas envie
du tout a dit bouvry sept et huit heures
par exemple sais c'est que j'ai passé
fait est en plus jeunes vu mon niveau en
dessin je crois que c'est juste pas une
tempête
oui c'est paint 100% paint voilà donc
c'est un mec avec un animal mort sur la
tête hein je pourrais faire une vidéo
juste sur le taux de panne de l'adie
beaux mecs
yes je viens de faire un dessin de vous
devant cette vidéo osée me dire que
c'est pas vrai tu peux l'enregistrer sur
une disquette s'adaptant à temps je vais
l'envoyer à du coup je vais faire un
cadeau il va kiffer alors mec maintenant
tu vas juste à l'ouvrier mon [ __ ] de
cadeaux qui est dans ta boîte aux
lettres pour me faire plaisir se plaît
tout est si lent alors attention
attention skis adibou aimé mon dessin
moment de vérité ce plan est une lettre
de toi elle est vraiment très jolie
mais avez vous plaît tu sais c'est un
dessin en fait il vient de faire une
réponse par défaut on est d'accord il
vient de dire qu'il aimait ma lettre
alors que c'est un dessin sont pas du
tout une lettre mais qu'on et d'auto
dans la maison dany boon sais pas si
vous vous souvenez de cette télé mec
mais alors ce qu'ont joué a dit bousquet
sacré pourquoi merci d'avoir choisi de
lui un dip ou la télé clip qui bouge qui
bouge qui bouge
sadate bel et bien de 2000 oui vraiment
c'est là dedans que tu pouvais retrouver
des comptines mec dont la comptine la
plus célèbre de ma génération
ensemble nous allons aussi pour jouer
des bouts nostalgie de toi trois petits
chats rapide un petit déficit pas merde
[Musique]
mais c'est squeeze 2001 voyez ça y est
c'est toi vu quoi ça me touche à la
mecque trois petits chiens à quoi trois
petits champs
il y avait aussi le poste de radio
qu'est-ce qui fait le besoin de place à
la rigolade à la rigolade hibou bien sûr
une petite fille arrive on court au dans
le salon vise à prévenir dont parle déjà
au courant un garçon de mondain mais
stop stop agathe a statut de gouverneur
est nous enchaîner deux blagues de mer
va t'en mec je crois vraiment que ce que
je suis devenu en termes de blagues
aujourd'hui je le dois entièrement à ce
poste de radio ce talent pour faire les
pires blague qui soit c'est lui qui m'a
tout appris et howie le premier jeu du
coût auquel j'ai joué c'était ce jeu qui
est dedans a dit bauer né sur un jeu
c'est shawn [ __ ] les mecs j'ai joué
tellement à ce jeu je m'en souviens très
bien d'ailleurs c'était trop facile je
me suis allé quand je me disais que
c'était trop simple et vraiment les
fumades de haller quoi
j'étais loin de me douter que j'allais
être pourri à tous les jeux auxquels
j'allais jouer plus tard clients là on
va arrêter on va arrêter vraiment a dit
murray devait quoi d'autre dans sa
maison il ya ça mais ça c'est un peu nul
faut juste customiser un masque on s'en
fout un peu on va pas se mentir
oh [ __ ] ils m'empêchent de revient
dans là je vais le tuer cet alien ouais
[Musique]
non parce que selon moi je te dirai rien
ah oui les graines on pouvait faire des
[ __ ] de plantation et sa poussée
jamais c'était génial ça il faut les
plantes et une par une ces vraiment
lausanne en faire on va pas se mentir
[Musique]
ça pose vraiment pas définitivement pas
un mec ça pousse au fallait juste
attendre super longtemps et comme
j'étais papa sur moi je vois là je viens
de réaliser un rêve [ __ ] ma première
fleur dany boom avec quinze ans après
abonnez-vous bomba nickelback
voilà j'ai réussi à faire avait repoussé
des [ __ ] de plantes au [ __ ] [ __ ]
dans les galets gallega les garder comme
tu l'as n'ont pas été boudés fonds s'est
accroché ses crochets ya yannick noah
des bouviers as tu des vip et la maison
mais que ça fait six fois qu'on y va
pour que tu fumes ça se fait pas réussi
à faire ça en devient cette vidéo fini
si bien les avc la fin de cette vidéo
sur adibou j'espère que vous a plu ce
cas n'hésitez pas à lui mais comme
d'habitude c'est vous a rappelé des
souvenirs et bien ma mission est réussie
et si ça vous a fait découvrir un jeu
éducatif de l'époque ben ma mission est
réussie aussi à l'époque les jeux vidéo
ça commençait vraiment à exploser donc
je pense que c'était bien adapté de
faire un jeu vidéo pour enfants c'est
vrai qu'on n'a plus trop maintenant des
jeux éducatifs des absents que ça a été
remplacé par des jouets éducatifs c'est
dans les rayons à jouéclub toys'r'us et
s et des jouets qu'ils apprennent chez
pas les couleurs ou des led sont
vraiment bien foutu parce qu'il arrive
vraiment à choper l'attention de
l'enfant quoi ah oui et c'est aussi été
remplacés par des jeux un mobile en fait
il ya plein de gamins ou le leu les
darons prêtent leur iphone ou l'ipad et
ils jouent à des jeux là dessus mais je
fais passer des jeux des jeux comme
adibou a dû booster vraiment pour les
enfants il y avait un univers trop cool
avec plusieurs personnes à prenez plein
de choses fin après cgc la nostalgie qui
parle [ __ ] je fais plein de bisous à
très vite sur a dit adil bouhaja des
bouts de chou et on finit sur une
anecdote saviez-vous que a dit veut dire
accompagnement didacticiel intelligent
ça fait un peu moins les verts allaient
bientôt
[Musique]
lotois nous y sommes prêts